we just got confirmation that Apple's
Ultra iPhone is coming but probably not
when you think it is and it's probably
not going to look like what you think is
going to look like so in this video I'm
going to explain all the different
things that have changed in terms of
leaks and we're gonna see what the new
15 Pro Models are coming with because we
just got a bunch of leaks in terms of
that as well so let's get started first
off I want to remind you guys of Mark
German's leak back in September that the
iPhone 15 Ultra could replace the pro
Max model next year which is now this
year in 2023 however he just came back
with a new power on newsletter saying
that apple is now considering a new
high-end iPhone alongside the pro and
pro Max so what that means is that we're
gonna have a pro model a pro Max and a
new high-end Ultra model so it's not
going to replace a pro Max it's going to
be in addition to it the only downside
is that it's not gonna happen this year
with the 15 lineup it's going to be part
of the iPhone 16 lineup or later so
since it's going to be a completely
separate and even more high-end iPhone
sort of like what Apple did with the
Apple watch Ultra a beef uh model what
is it going to look like well thankfully
Jonas or Jonas on Twitter made a cool
awesome project of what it could
actually look like and as you can see
here's a little sneak peek of the USBC
Port which actually has orange around it
which looks amazing and a speaker Grille
that matches the Apple watch Ultra and
then here you go here's another image
he's saying 12 millimeter plus thick the
ultra concept and oh my goodness this
looks absolutely insane and amazing if
this is what it ends up looking like I'm
gonna be blown away and I have to buy
one of these because this looks
beautiful you can see the natural Titan
material just like the Apple watch Ultra
you have this nice beige glass on the
back that's kind of curved around it
with a nice thin camera bump which has
these concave camera bumps on the inside
just absolutely looks beautiful I love
how the actual buttons have this wrapped
around it just like the Apple watch
Ultra this looks absolutely insane
especially adding an additional button
to the action button on the side just
like the Apple watch I mean this is
amazing I hope it's gonna be like this
however I think it could actually be
something completely different and hear
me out because this makes sense what if
this is Apple's way of introducing their
new iPhone fold next year what if the
iPhone 16 Ultra is actually the iPhone
fold that's one way they can get away
with a higher price imagine 14.99 1500
for a foldable iPhone because if you
think about it if they're keeping the
pro and pro Max as it is how else are
you going to differentiate a new model
to make it worth spending more well you
have a foldable and going even further
markerman elaborated saying that it
makes sense for Apple to eventually
shift to one entry iPhone to Pro iPhones
and one Ultra iPhone so basically you're
gonna have the regular iPhone 16 then
you have the 16 pro and pro Max and then
the 16 Ultra that's four just like we
have a choice of four nice Flagship
iPhones right now so that basically
means the plus is going to get canceled
it's going to get out of there we just
have one basic one and three high-end
and that is why I think the highest end
model could be affordable it just makes
sense to me but for now we can expect
the entire iPhone 15 lineup to be
identical to the one that we have now
except all of the iPhone 15s are gonna
get the dynamic Island so so the notch
is going away for a good across all
models forever finally and all of the
Pro Models are going to be getting
titanium frames so the pro the pro Max
everything else all titanium but either
way this year's iPhone 15 lineup is
going to be the iPhone 15 the 15 plus
the 15 Pro and the 15 Pro Max exactly
how it is right now with the 14s so now
let's get into the leaks of what we
should expect for those Pro Models but
before I get into that I've got to talk
about this the magic stand case from our
partner case Q which basically combines
the best and most Wanted aspects of a
case into one you've not only got a
great and durable design with strong
Maxi magnets built in but the magsafe
ring is literally on a hinge so you can
use it as a finger grip or a 40 to 120
degree stand and the best part is that
it folds back completely flush with the
case so it doesn't interfere with any
other Max save charges or accessories so
check out the link and all of the
discount info in the video description
below and now let's get back to the
iPhone 15 pro and pro Max features we
just got an awesome leak from shrimp
Apple Pro talking about what to expect
in terms of the design the display sizes
will stay identical to the iPhone 14
lineup as you can see right here however
the Pro 15 models will have thinner
bezels with curved edges yes curved
edges on the sides however the display
is still flat so we still have a flat
display only the bezels will curve but
the most interesting part that he added
was that the source described that the
iPhone 15 Pro Max is very beautiful with
the thinner bezels and curved edges
creating the same effect like on the
Apple watch but then it gets a little
bit confusing because Joe resignal added
up a couple of the features that we
should expect saying we should expect
curved bezels like the iPhone 10 to 11
Pro with even thinner bezels like the
Apple watch how however a flat frame on
the side just like the iPhone 12 Pro or
newer with a titanium frame like on the
Apple watch Ultra so how can you explain
that well so check out my renders that I
created with renders by shylash as you
can see right here you have only the
bezels that will curve while the display
is flat so if you look closely you have
a flat glass panel just imagine this
also the same on the front however where
it gets closer to the bezels or the
sides that's where the glass curves so
that you still have a flat titanium side
or frame this is exactly what I think it
could look like but then imagine this
being on the front of course another
good example is LD voba who made these
renders showing that you have a flat
frame but the actual glass curves now in
my opinion you're not going to have this
squarish glass camera bump it's going to
be all flat but the glass is what curves
into the flat side side so you can see
these images here and this isn't
actually really cool effect you can see
on the front the glass curves into a
flat display and on the back this is
basically exactly what Apple did with
the iPhone 4 as you can see in this
image you have flat sides frame and you
have protruding glass on the front and
the back and it's curved just like that
I imagine Apple's gonna bring that back
to the iPhone 15 Pro Models for the new
design but now let's get into some of
the other features including the
performance and how it's going to
compare to the rest of the competition
the first thing is an internal Apple
document leak that confirms Wi-Fi 6E is
coming to only the 15 Pro Models then we
also have the confirmation from inxical
that we're getting solid state buttons
on the new high-end iPhone 15 pro and
pro Max models which is going to be a
really cool design change because
there's going to the additional taptic
engines for both the volume and power
buttons so it's going to feel really
really nice and then Joe resignal put up
this nice little list of showing the pro
features that the iPhone 15 Pros are
going to get but not the regular 15s for
example we're going to have the a17 chip
which I'm going to talk about in a
second Wi-Fi 6E like I mentioned a
higher speed USBC Port which is going to
be nice maybe even Thunderbolt then
titanium frame even thinner bezels 8
gigs of RAM solid state buttons and at
least 6X optical zoom on just the pro
Max model however in 2024 next year even
the iPhone 16 Pro regular model is going
to be getting that Periscope lens which
is going to be awesome and now let's get
into some performance benchmarks
comparing the a17 that we're gonna get
to the brand new s23 Ultra with the
Snapdragon 8 gen 2. the issue with the
new s23 Ultra is that even though p
unique performance for graphics is
higher as you can see right here in
3dmark extreme all the way up there
beating the 14 pro Max the actual
stability is worse because as you can
see the low is much worse than Apple's
iPhone 14 pro Max right here you can see
it overheats and clocks down which is a
really bad sign for the Samsung and a
good sign for the iPhone now Dame Tech
also did gentian impact FPS tests and as
you can see the average was 53.7 FPS
which is actually quite bad because if
you can see how it compares to the 14
pro Max the a16 chip gets 59 FPS almost
perfect 60 in that game compared to the
s22 ultra with a cooler that got 50.9 so
the 14 pro Max is already beating it but
now the a17 ship is going to be built on
three Anna meter from tsmc the n3b
process with LP ddr5 memory which means
it's going to be really good it's going
to be very efficient and the reason this
matters is because that a17 bionic chip
is going to be 35 more energy efficient
enabling longer battery life so the
efficiency is going to allow Apple to
clock up the performance of the graphics
now what some people might not know is
that the a16 bionic chip was supposed to
have a brand new GPU with Hardware Ray
tracing support but Apple had to cancel
it and literally go back to the same
exact GPU that's in the a15 chip and
here's some proof geeker one on YouTube
literally showed that gpu-wise there's
literally no difference between a15 and
a16 using die shots it's the same copy
paste no difference at all Apple had to
can cancel the new GPU but the benefit
of that is that the new a17 chip coming
in the 15 Pro will have that new GPU and
it will be based on tsmc's new three
nanometer process so it's the perfect
combination because the reason they
canceled it was because the a16 new GPU
was getting too hot leading to bad
battery life and bad thermal throttling
but three nanometer fixes that so the
new a17 Chip is going to be killer it's
going to be a huge upgrade for a
performance and efficiency and of course
we have those new renders by Celeste
that I showed you the design is going to
be amazing on the new pro and pro Max
models and then next year we're hoping
for that new Ultra iPhone which might
even be a foldable so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and these new leaks
if you did let me know down in the
comment section below if anything stood
out definitely click the circle about to
subscribe subscribe for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]